what's up everybody it's lauren disney
and marvel just sent me a
loki mystery box now i have actively
avoided watching other people unbox
these because i want to be surprised
of what's in it i believe i have an idea
of one thing that's in it but
let's unbox this thing and figure it out
supposedly
it's pretty cool which which i would
expect
oh
tva
that's pretty cool i'll show you guys
that in a second
oh wow oh
[Music]
cool all right
but all right let's see what we got
oh that's really cool
i want to mess this up but
it's a miss minix clock for
time always it's in this minute clock
that's freaking cool
wow 3.5 cordless wood ball clock
instruction panel little miss mini club
that's cool i have to put that in the
background there
awesome
and i want to read this
it says dear recruit on behalf of
everyone at the time variance authority
we'd like to say welcome we are created
by the time keepers
to protect the sacred timeline we're
excited to present you with
your new recruit package filled with
everything you'll need to be an
incredible worker on your first day on
the job
we're thrilled for you to help protect
the timeline from variants such as
loki lafay sun one of our most recent
case files
good luck and remember time passes
differently in the tva
for more information start streaming
marvel studios
loki and original series on disney plus
for all time always
that's pretty cool all right what do we
have in here
this is pretty cool
all right
oh no way oh no way the first thing i
noticed is
a tesseract
are these sticky notes they are
it's like a tesseract sticky note that's
pretty cool that's pretty funny
i think i might keep it locked up for a
second okay what do we have here
[Laughter]
they sent me socks time variants
authority socks
that's so awesome it's like a full thing
got a loki pin here
i know there's a glare from the light oh
okay this is what i figured was coming
because i asked for my jacket size
before they sent this
no way
no way oh cool
i have to try that one right now
that's so cool this is tva
oh no way oh thank you so much marvel
thank you disney
all right what else we got here tva
stapler
ah tape every tva agent needs their tape
uh i don't know what this is oh
oh oh that's really cool
a tva pen
wow
disney marvin how to do it i'm not sure
what this oh it's a mug oh
no way that's so cool
no way look at that
wow that's pretty cool
that was done incredibly well
that's pretty cool status sign here
state that's everything you ever said
that's pretty cool wow well what a cool
thing to do for the premiere
wow thank you so much marvel thank you
so much disney this is by far
one of the coolest things i've ever
received this jacket is pretty cool
i'm gonna wear this all the time i'm
gonna wear it during the live streams uh
if you guys haven't checked out loki yet
i think you've already known by now
because i've been stating it enough
times
it's probably my favorite disney plush
show so far actually is
i can't wait for everybody to see
episode two um and if you haven't seen
episode one yet it's not streaming on
disney plus this is pretty cool thank
you to all of you
for all the support that you've given me
to allow this to be possible love you
all
see you next time woof